[Music]
there's a few ways in which infectious
disease may impact who we find sexually
attractive so if for example in cultures
where infectious disease is highly
prevalent people tend to have place more
emphasis on beauty so you know skin free
of any kind of pock marks and also more
symmetrical features because what
happens is that if you have an
infectious disease when you're young it
can derail development and that's part
of the reason why people's features may
be a little bit more asymmetric if
they've if they're more vulnerable to
infectious disease there's also a
Memphis that we're more attracted to
people whose odors are signified that
they have very different immune systems
from ourselves and the way it works is
this that believe it or not odor
correlates with how your immune system
functions and we all very individually
in how susceptible we are two different
kinds of infection and basically the
research suggests that were Iraq we're
most attracted to people who are most
different from us in terms of how their
immune system functions so if we made
and have children our children are going
to have very varied genes there and as a
result if say you know an effect
terrible infection is spreading around
you might lose one child but you're not
going to lose all your children because
they're gonna have very varied immune
systems in terms of you know what could
make them sick and what they're more
resistant to I you got bacteria as an
extension of parasitic manipulation even
though I don't think that most gut
bacteria are parasite so in fact I would
call them symbiotic manipulators and the
reason I'm so interested in them is
because
they do manipulate behavior you know in
fashion not totally unlike parasitic
manipulators and the way they're able to
do this is there's over a thousand
different species of bacteria that
inhabit our guts and there are species
that turn out basically every single
neurotransmitter that you have in your
brain and they churn out hormones so
stress hormones and hormones that
regulate our appetite and energy levels
so the research suggests that the the
bacteria in our gut influence everything
from you know whether you're energetic
or sluggish happy or sad anxious and
calm maybe even whether you're fat or
thin and there is some research now it
look exploring what fecal implants if if
you transplant feces from one person to
another
there's looking to see what some of the
effects are some examples would be there
been efforts to show that by
transplanting feces from one person to
another that you may even be able to
influence their appetite so far I don't
think they've had too much success there
are one or two examples though of for
example a woman who was getting the
fecal transplant actually to treat a
digestive disease and it's called
Clostridium difficile so they have shown
by the way the fecal transplant is very
effective in treating some of these
digestive disorders and this particular
woman wanted to get the the fecal donor
she wanted to be her daughter who was
then around 15 or 16 years of age and
within a short period of time after
getting the fecal transplant the mother
suddenly for the first time in her life
was starting to become overweight and
she actually started ventually became
obese and she was convinced it was
related to the transplant and within
just a year two of her daughter being
the donor the daughter became obese so
there is the findings like that
make scientists wonder if fecal
transplant might actually in future you
know just as it can cause obesity maybe
if you get the donor from a thin person
maybe you can prevent obesity it's not
very you know appetizing to contemplate
it you may be happy to hear that that
scientists are hoping to just purify you
know the useful strains of bacteria and
then concentrate them in a capsule they
call them crap stools so they're hoping
that they'll be able to use these
capsules in instead of you know getting
an actual you know fecal transplant
which they do that using that instrument
like that they used to do a colonoscopy
that's how they insert feces up your
intestinal tract
[Music]
you